22 ans que Marie Viessmann délivre des
médicaments au comptoir de sa pharmacie
dans quelques jours elle va prendre sa
retraite mais la mort dans l'âme elle
n'a trouvé personne pour acheter son
fond de commerce
c'est vraiment un crève-cœur c'est
vraiment le mot pas de repreneur ça veut
dire il y a aucune transmission de mon
métier de ce que nous avons fait ici
avec mon équipe
nous ne pouvons pas transmettre ce que
nous avons fait ici c'est un des piliers
de Migennes et on voit on sait que ça va
fermer
la pharmacie est la plus ancienne de la
commune depuis plus d'un siècle elle a
vu défiler des générations et des
générations de migenois ici les clients
sont pour la plupart des habitués tous
sont dépités je comprends pas parce que
l'informatique ça marche c'est ça
marchera de plus en plus bah oui je
regrette oui c'était juste à côté puis
quand on est habitué à une pharmacie
c'est pas changé quoi vous êtes obligé
d'aller ailleurs puisque personne ne
reprend
beaucoup parce que j'aime bien
Sandrine Marie préparatrice travaille
ici depuis 32 ans avant elle sa propre
mère avait passé 35 ans derrière ces
mêmes comptoirs je pense qu'on n'arrive
pas encore à se projeter c'est compliqué
parce que on est encore dans le
roulement on va dire et je pense que
quand ça va fermer ça va être compliqué
je pense voilà voilà je gère trouvé
ailleurs mais je me suis donné au moins
15 jours pour m'en remettre je pense que
voilà il va falloir un petit peu de
temps pour avaler tout ça quoi et
digérer digérer l'info la Pharmacie de
Paris ne sera pas la seule à fermer à la
fin du mois celle du Luxembourg va elle
aussi mettre la clé sous la porte à
Migennes il ne restera alors que deux
officines pour un bassin de 15000
habitants c'est moitié moins que la
moyenne nationale